scp-682 vs scp-539  could the perfect distraction take 682's  attention away from the one thing it  cares about hatred a member of d-class  personnel was sent into scp-682's  containment chamber carrying scp-539  then the doors were shut behind them  terrified that scp-682 would kill them  the d-class threw scp-539 early in an  attempt to distract it as soon as  scp-539 was thrown the site experienced  a system malfunction in the containment  chamber an acid pump was activated  during this malfunction trapping scp-682  for approximately 20 minutes before it  was deactivated by site maintenance  staff by the time staff reached the  containment chamber 85 of 682's body had  been destroyed  scp-539 was found nearby and the d-class  was completely gone three hours later  scp-682 was completely recovered plus an  additional pair of legs grown during the  healing process